[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time for pft on yahoo sports peter king
mike floyer some of the big stories in
the national football league and a
stunner on sunday the las vegas raiders
get their first signature victory as
residents of nevada by going into
missouri and taking down the defending
super bowl champions 40 to 32. peter
have the raiders given the rest of the
league a blueprint of sorts on how to
slow down patrick mahomes and company
just enough to outscore them
you know when you think about this mike
one of the funny things about it is that
the blueprint that the oakland raiders
showed is that
they are trying to
capture
the kansas city blueprint
you know and because think about it the
denver broncos and the oakland raiders
both
this off season
did stuff
to try to counterbalance
what you know how far ahead of the
division
the chiefs have gotten and they've
gotten ahead of that division
of this division because of speed on
offense
and when you look at the weaponry the
chiefs have
and then you look at what
the raiders have done
and you just say listen there's a reason
why they wanted
henry ruggs over cd lamb and jerry judy
and that's because he's two ticks faster
uh and and really can wreak havoc with a
secondary
and you don't really know the difference
between four to six speed and four four
speed until you watch henry rugs or
really until you watch tyreek hill but i
think that's the biggest thing the
second thing the second thing is
they have not put all of their eggs in
that one basket look at josh jacobs
you know look at the tight end group
that they have now
and and i would say that mike the way
that what the las vegas raiders showed
the nfl is
get a lot of weapons diverse weapons on
offense
you're not going to stop patrick mahomes
regularly you're just not
get diverse weapons on offense so that
you can go toe-to-toe with them in a
heavyweight offensive fight
yeah he's gonna score his points
typically he's gonna score his points in
bunches you just have to deal with it
accept it and look for ways
to finally score more than he does it
helps if you can slow him down a little
bit like the raiders did in the second
half there's no reason blitzing the guy
that's something dean p's the former
titans defensive coordinator said last
year he's still going to get away from
you so drop extra guys into coverage
confuse him that way make him take more
time and maybe he loses sight of a max
crosby who got him in a way that we
rarely see patrick mahomes get hit from
behind because he always knows where
everyone is and also peter you got to
have the killer instinct this is where
the ravens went wrong a couple of weeks
ago you get fourth and short inside the
10. you go for it you got to get a
touchdown like the raiders did in the
first half when they're fourth and short
in chip shop field goal range no forget
about three we need seven you gotta get
seven whenever you can if you have any
hope peter of having more points than
the chiefs and mahomes have when the
game ends
i think also mike one of the things that
helps
is to have a coach on your staff
who knows andy reid very well and knows
how andy reid thinks and that coach just
happens to be john gruden and i'm just
going to make this point
that
john gruden
knows
that andy reid is simply going to try to
get faster and faster every year it's
why one of the things i reported last
april in the draft is that the chiefs
were thinking seriously
if
uh
you know if henry ruggs fell down into
the 20s to try to move up and to get him
and everybody said that's absurd why
would they do that because the shelf
life for the really fast slight guys is
not long and you have to make sure that
every game you play
look at sammy watkins he's out for a
little bit now he because he always is
so you get as many of those guys as you
can
and cycle them into your offense and
that is what i believe you're going to
see john gruden and mike mayok do in
future drafts
from the chiefs perspective they'll be
extra motivated the next time they play
it'll be monday night in buffalo we'll
see if they can rebound from their first
loss since november of 2019. we'll see
you next time for more pft on yahoo
video
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports